great lineup tonight terrific show this
evening who's yawning I'm sorry that is
it that's that's Tony that's our
cameraman I'm sorry ladies I'm and Tony
why are you yawning oh sorry Conan I had
a late night last night and totally be
okay well I got a bite now what did you
do last night Tony
oh I I attended the big Pete a premiere
the Pete ape premiere yeah yeah it was
the gala premiere screening of the Pete
a anyway sorry are you on so loud wait
I'm sorry Tony are you talking about v-p
tape the one mentioned in the steel
dossier right wait a minute Tony you're
saying you saw that Pete a geez yeah the
whole crew did right guys yeah that's
amazing how did you guys all get to see
the P tape well it turns out I had
accumulated enough VIP perk points with
my FBI master card
well the FBI has a credit card yeah the
FBI MasterCard earn points towards
exclusive VIP experiences last year I
earned enough points to find out who
really killed JFK
I was surprised who it was and how well
his acting career has gone since then
this year I had enough points to take
all the guys to the PTA premiere it was
quite a night check it out
hi I'm tensley BIP reporting to you live
from the gala premiere of the PTA
[Music]
we have been hearing that this p tape is
quite emotional do you have any thoughts
to share on that yeah you know I got
pretty worked up a couple of times in
fact even just right now thinking about
the movie a little bit you know when you
go into a P tape you don't expect much
you got your laundry list of things that
you expect to see you know you expect to
see P and it had that it was fantastic
as someone to can't panic camera I was
impressed were there any surprises in
the film for you yeah the surprise was
that I was in a theater watching a P
tape
I liked it with Nick Fury showed up at
the end okay so we saw the premiere but
what was on the PTA sorry they made all
800 of us promise not to tell anyone
what was on it now if you'll excuse me
I've got a talk show to shoot Tony I'm
asking you what was on the P tape
sorry I can't tell you oh well by the
way when you tape your show I tape it
right now that's what I thought get back
to work
[Applause]
you